how do we learn from you and the seals
to handle our pain feel the fear and do
it anyway that famous quote I want to
tell you a little bit about the science
so you fly and you go up to 14,000 feet
and somebody opens the door and in that
moment you realize you've never been in
a freaking airplane with the door open
teller wanna be happy build a life not
just a business
oh hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back it lack a belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you two
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believed life and learn how to destroy
fear and pain
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one conquer your mind with Will Smith
skydiving is a really interesting
confront with fear and you know you take
a drink with your friends and somebody
says yeah we should go skydiving
tomorrow and you go yeah we'll go
skydiving yeah and you go home but you
by yourself you like me right you like
well yeah I mean they was drunk too so
then that night you're laying in your
bed and you just get killed and you're
terrified you keep imagining over and
over again jumping out of an airplane
and you can't figure out why you would
do that so you get there and then you
have this safety brief and you're
standing there and the guys that tell
you what the chute doesn't open what's
going to happen as you're doing you a
lot of help with what could happen so
you get onto the airplane and you're
sitting there and and you know it's
extra because you're sitting on some
dudes lap some stranger trying to make
small talk yeah man
so you guys would be you be jumping with
people all the time so you fly and you
go up to 14,000 feet and somebody opens
the door and that moment you realize
you've never been in a freaking airplane
with the door open
terror terror terror talent and then
people start going out of the airplane
and the guy walks you up to the end of
the thing and you're standing and your
toes are on the edge and you're looking
out down to death they say on three two
any pushes you want to because people
grab one three
and you thought out at an airplane
and in one second you realize that it's
the most blissful experience of your
life you are flying
there's zero fear you realize at the
point of maximum danger is the point of
minimum fear the lesson for me was why
were you scared in your bed the night
before what do you need that fear for
everything up to the stepping out
there's actually no reason to be scared
and then in that moment all of a sudden
where you should be terrified is the
most blissful experience of your life
and God placed the best things in life
on the other side of fear also if you
want to have more self-love and
motivation check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join under
description below it takes such a
desperate obsessive focus to to excel on
assert honor on the level that I want to
make movies it's about what you're
saying to yourself but it also comes at
work so whenever I was getting beat down
physically mentally spiritually whatever
I was going through just saying you know
I would put you know you can't hurt me
our minds are designed to stop you at
all costs from doing anything that might
hurt you rule number two find your why
with David Dawkins how do we learn from
you and the seals to handle our pain
we're in the midst of pain what because
it hurts and it hurts physically
sometimes obviously and then some of us
are dealing with emotional pain mhmmm
what are we doing those moments when
we're feeling the most pain and we're
going I cannot go one more second so
this is the thing a few years ago the
Navy SEALs designed a program called the
buds buds prep program in my last two
years in the military I did twenty-one
years they sent me down to Great Lakes
Chicago and we were training these guys
to get ready to go to Butz steel
training cuz a lot of guys weren't
getting through we thought this program
will help them get through so these guys
would leave our program studs push-ups
sit-ups swimming everything but the
numbers were the exact same so I was
scratching my hand like hollow work
these guys go through two
this before you get the budgets to
acquit yeah and we asked you a question
in a second no go for it I started going
back through my mind and realizing one
thing we were building bigger stronger
faster quitters why is that if you don't
work on the one thing the most powerful
weapon in the world is your mind yeah so
the answer your question is this whether
it be physical pain or mental pain we
all have to start from zero with pain
and what that means is if you don't go
back we all have something that bothers
us everybody in this world is insecure
about something that's right something
like maybe your family your mom your dad
your brother your sister your wife your
husband your kids something has messed
you up and whenever you're in physical
pain even though you might not be
thinking about that mental stuff that
happened to you
your mind is thinking about it all these
dungeons that we've created all these
trap doors that our life has created
most of time we quit is because we don't
have any mental tools to get us through
the other side so my whole thing for
people is you have to examine why are
you doing it in the first place what
makes people quit so much in still
training in all other special ops
training is the mind it's always
comfortable to sit there you watch the
Navy SEALs show Discovery Channel you're
in a 72 degree house oh yeah you have
your lemonade you milkshake with
everything yeah I can do that oh sure
you're comfortable although I'll say
this I never say that well some people
do yeah a lot of folks think you know
because it feels very comfortable in
that comfortable vowel I totally
absolutely the second you get out there
in that environment where it's 40
degrees like in my throat health we you
know we had a guy died of pulmonary
oedema died out there and my third hell
week you have to really want what Abel
you know whatever you're going for you
know if not all these questions that
come up like it's a hot how you go one
more step further yeah your mind is
going to ask you all these questions
haki go one more step further if
you don't have the answers today and I
can't give them to you yeah you have to
know why am I here for me when I was
going through SIL training I was willing
to die so all these negative questions
that kept on coming up my head I had the
answer form it's those people that don't
have the answer for those negative
questions right and and if you can't ask
those questions you will quit and real
number three the last one before a very
special bonus clip is feel the fear and
do it anyway with Mel Robbins feel the
fear and do it anyway that famous quote
I want to tell you a little bit about
the science so there's this famous
neuroscience is called Antonio Damasio
and he did a really interesting study
where he discovered that our body senses
fear before our mind even realizes it
and when fear or danger speaking to your
boss calling a prospect going to the gym
when you're not proud of the way that
you look and you know it's not fear like
terror it's more that low-grade
agitation in your body
I felt it yesterday because I went to a
bootcamp class yesterday and I'm not in
good shape and I don't do bootcamp
classes and Kendall and I are staying at
this hotel where holy cow everybody
seems like there's some sort of
professional weightlifter or Instagram
model and so it was really intimidating
and I could feel that agitation in my
body that's the kind of fear I'm talking
about I'm not talking about the
paralysis fear your life is threatened
and you really are in a life-or-death
situation I'm talking about the
low-grade agitation that is there when
you're about to do something that makes
you feel a little uncomfortable so when
fear or danger is sensed in the body
your body begins a stress response
before your mind even catches up and if
you want to take control of your life
you've got to take control of that
physical state and it starts with
catching these moments everyone when you
start to feel it now I have a special
bonus clip with marie forleo and how to
follow your fear that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video to
taking action you
we go question up one where do you need
to just feel the fear and do it anyway
number two what is your strong why and
number three how will you conquer your
mind today also if you made it this far
in the video I want to celebrate you
give me a hashtag believe in the
comments as well you know it seems like
you can't open a book or read a blog
post these days without hearing somebody
tell you to follow your passion or
follow your bliss or follow your heart
and yes I have said those things too but
today I want to talk about the power of
going in what can often feel like the
opposite direction I want to talk about
the power of following your fear I'm not
talking about following your very useful
fear of big moving vehicles and walking
in front of a bus nor am i talking about
doing anything stupid or irresponsible
that could ruin you financially what I
am talking about though is the power of
following good fear directive fear the
kind of fear that you feel when you have
an idea that just won't leave you alone
an idea about doing something that
you've always wanted to do something
that's different and bold and kind of
risky where part of you saying oh no I
actually couldn't do that but the deeper
wiser part of you wants this thing so
damn bad and the moment you imagine
yourself going for it you have worries
like you know will people laugh at me
will they ignore me maybe this isn't
even really an idea what if I do it and
it sucks
am I gonna destroy my reputation am I
gonna lose my marriage and my family and
mind up living on the streets my friend
Steven Pressfield talks about this kind
of fear in the war of art and he says
remember our rule of thumb the more
scared we are of a work or calling the
more sure we can be that we have to do
it and he continues the more fear we
feel about a specific enterprise the
more certain we can be that that
enterprise is important to us and the
growth of our soul
if you want to know why your comfort
zone is destroying your life check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy continue to believe and
I'll see you there the way I continue to
stretch myself at my old antenna is I'd
encourage good people often become
seduced by the chatter